the jurogan experience i watched
idiocracy this morning oh boy
dude it [ __ ] holds up
it holds doesn't it oh my god it's funny
i never saw the whole thing before it
was one of those movies that i just
for whatever reason i just never saw the
whole thing it was just well it kind of
yeah i didn't have much of a release so
it didn't
no it they it was um
i mean
to be fair like it was a weird movie it
was hard to market it's a funny [ __ ]
movie man
it's funny i mean i i watched it in the
gym while i was working out i was
cracking up
oh nice to hear it was
really good it was like surprisingly
funny there was some great stuff about
it when
when it's just the very smart couple
that's holding off and having children
and the dumb people keep [ __ ]
yeah that was uh
i feel like i
really made the whole movie just to make
that sequence
that was one of those rare times patrick
and uh darlene the two actors that it's
the only time i think this has ever
happened they i think they were
auditioning them in pairs and
they auditioned and i kind of looked at
like two or three more people and then
said okay let's just cast them it's
perfect
that guy was so good patrick fisher yeah
it's it was such a good movie man it's
just like thanks and it's so interesting
like looking at the world in 2022
it's like the only thing you missed was
social media
yeah i mean
i keep thinking about all the stuff i
missed i i
yeah i feel that movie was i feel like
it was cursed to begin with um
everything that went wrong went wrong
everything that could go wrong went
wrong like
and it was
so many things like we shot it here in
austin it's supposed to take place in a
drought and it was like the rainiest
summer
we had to keep killing grass which feels
really awful to do oh god but but we um
how do you do that
oh yeah you put a like a giant piece of
like tarp cardboard over it for like two
nights or something
but then sometimes i have to put
gasoline on it or something
it just feels horrible to kill grass
um
yeah i don't know and then i feel like
the curse of the movie kind of just
spread out into the world or something
but uh
one i was just thinking about this
because i can't i have a hard time
watching it because it just brings back
so many stressful memories but um
because it was difficult to make yeah
just we were you know
barely had an impossible schedule and
and then in post
you know they
they just cut we had a bad test
screening and they just cut the effects
budget down and
but i mean you know they did
pay for the movie to get made so i
appreciate it but um
yeah i was just thinking that so there
was the wardrobe uh
woman whatever i don't know what what do
you costume designers the official title
she
you know she had a limited budget also
and for the shoes so this we shot in
2004
she goes she tells me okay there's a
startup and it was crocs but they
weren't out in the world yet but it was
a small company and she goes look at
these are these horrible plastic shoes
she said we could really save a lot of
money just put everyone in these things
and then i said well what if but what if
by the time the movie comes out what if
everyone's what if these become popular
people are wearing them she said oh
these are never going to become popular
no one would ever wear these things are
horrible and then yeah there you go
and then but then it took two years for
the movie to come out then everyone's
but then people are like oh that's
pretty funny that you put everyone in
crocs
they did kind of become popular right
yeah and then they're they're not around
much anymore but they were really
popular they're really popular right now
they came back they came back in the
last like two years all of a sudden what
do you mean who's wearing them uh right
post malone how to like uh deal with
them i think justin bieber did too
people are putting like pins on them and
stuff they're very popular right now
pins yeah like little they're uh like
little like pins yeah oh like shirt pins
yeah yeah yeah yeah i should
stop talking [ __ ] i know people wear
them a lot of guys wear them like in
camps
you bring them to camp like they're camp
shoes
they wear crocs around camp because
they're light you know if you're wearing
like hiking boots all day and then
you're camping you wear crocs at night
and then you're going to get around fire
you get lunch
so this is a new thing i've only seen it
popping because they were i'd heard they
were
they were
interested in bankruptcy like five years
ago or something maybe i heard wrong
wow maybe they were maybe somebody came
in with yeah i mean with funding and
took a distressed property and i don't
get it i don't i was always confused
like there's so many options for shoes
why would you ever buy those there's all
kinds of slippers you could have yeah um
there's no need for those i don't get
them for camping though like can't you
gonna get like ticks all over here no i
think the idea is
like
hunters wear them so like when you're in
the woods and you're hiking you're
wearing these like very kind of rigid
hiking boots and then when you're just
around the campfire oh they wear these
little crocs okay because they weigh
nothing you know they're not oh okay
yeah they are light yeah and they
provide you with protection from sticks
and [ __ ]
okay
and then wear them like you know over
socks
i see so they're horrific looking
don't look good
that's why that's why i wanted them in
the movie what the [ __ ] is this they're
fat there's six hundred dollar crocs
these are fashion crocs cut the [ __ ]
[ __ ] i thought they were fake they are
uh those are real they're real six
hundred dollar crocs with uh some kind
of a heel what does the bottom of that
heel look like
like a peg like a nail
looks like a nail is going through that
is so strange
you know what i don't get this tradition
correct what's the story with the strap
at the top of the foot sport mode
they all have straps there's like yeah
the one thing about us
when you need to run and you gotta
you need to do some action you're doing
[ __ ]
put it on your heel so it doesn't fall
off kind of sprinting wait 600 bucks is
that how much yeah they're real 600.
that's how dumb people are
put that in your new movie
yeah i know i wish i could remake that
what would you do different
well like you said i probably probably
would have had more
staring at phones and stuff i mean i
nobody saw that coming though
yeah
um well there's also ohio right because
you filmed it it was released in what
2005 2006
filmed it in 2004 yeah so if you think
about like phones
back then it was all flip phones yeah
they were starting to come out with the
nokia
um
but yeah the iphone i don't think was
there that was seven it was a yeah it
was about to come out yeah and but and
even then like everybody thought that
was kind of like a novelty nobody ever
thought it would be like
a almost requirement for life yeah and
also i wrote it in two i started writing
in 2001 and then
it's writer eitan cohen i wrote a draft
with him i wrote an outline and then so
that was like 2002
i think or 2003 that we wrote it so it
was like
pretty far away from all this stuff
happening
that's the only thing you missed though
i mean even like a dumbing down of
people you nailed
yeah i was i was sort of i was thinking
of it like so i had
i had the idea in the 90s but i remember
um
when uh
in 2001
in the summer um
uh well it was it was the year 2001 i'd
seen the movie 2001 again and thought
wouldn't that be about that'd have been
funny if that movie instead of
everything being pristine advanced
civilization it was like
giant walmarts and the jerry springer
show and like what if what if that movie
made in the 70s was actually
that accurate and i just kind of thought
of a graph of like everything from
from whenever that movie was made like
71 to the year that it was 2001 if you
just kept that progression going and
just like
more crass foul language in the
mainstream more like just everybody
getting dumber and dumber and just
advertising everywhere i don't know it's
just
it's sort of a
i also
wrote it i owed fox a screenplay and i
pitched two or three different things
and they said oh that's the commercial
one that's one you should make and
i didn't think they would make it i just
it was fun to write why didn't you think
they would make it
it just seemed too weird
[Laughter]
but uh you know they saw it you know
anything in the future sounds fun and
like a
big broad comedy um
but uh yeah then they
it just it was more fun to write than it
was to make i mean nothing against
anybody involved it was just like a very
difficult schedule a lot of stuff went
wrong had 65 speaking parts in it
which you don't even when you're writing
just oh and then there's this and it's
like oh yeah you have to cast every one
of those people
you